um this weekend I was out with some
friends and there was a Paparazzi guy
and he was uh to attack me personally
and my family personally and I was I was
genuinely hurt by this
in response I wanted to hurt him back
and I said the most hurtful word that I
could think of at that moment last week
he's been apologizing for that
homophobic slurry man I didn't mean it
in a homophobic way have a good day
enjoy suck my dick oh a real bully
if someone says something that hurts you
or angers you
use me as an example of what not to do
you let my mistake be a lesson to anyone
who's feeling insecure at any moment and
does something stupid I really said what
I feel and uh I just hope people can
learn from
the mistake that I made that's good that
you came out and you
thank you